hallo leute und viele grüße aus singapur
das video in german english switchback
long as you probably never been in
vietnam
es soll hier ihr könnt sie ja noch nie
ist sexy vierten episode in vietnam will
firmen in singapur
what they will be on line access today
das video upload von episoden uns mit
das video der disney destatis kari
antwortet episode julien's auctions von
audience rubin german speakers 11
sie könnte bis hier im test your
germanwings kings los geht's unsere
erste frage heute ist von christian
david kris alles was er schreibt hallo
kari ich habe eine frage warum haben sie
das werk verlassen mit haben benutzt
verlassen ist ein bewegungs verb oder
nicht
seine frage ist zu unserem video haben
wird es sein wie ihr wisst haben wir ein
super easy german video gemacht zum
thema perfekt und hilfs werben
manchmal benutzt man haben manchmal sein
wir haben euch erklärt dass man sein
immer dann benutzt wenn sich bei einer
bewegung ein ort ändert oder ein zustand
und du hast recht christian das
verlassen ein komisches verb ist und ich
habe mich auch gefragt warum man sagt
ich habe die wohnung verlassen und nicht
ich bin die wohnung verlassen denn wenn
man sagt verlassen ja es heißt man
bewegt sich und man ändert einen ort
vorher war man in einer wohnung jetzt
ist man nicht mehr in der wohnung und ja
falls sie jemand von euch deutschen
lehrern zum beispiel das erklären kann
würde ich mich sehr freuen
denn dass es auch etwas was ich logisch
nicht nachvollziehen und nicht verstehen
kann
ich freue mich auf eure erklärung dazu
wenn ihr eine habt vielleicht ist es
auch eine ausnahme
charlotte riedner schreibt unter unser
video studieren in deutschland
ich dachte in deutschland muss man fürs
studium nichts bezahlen
das ist richtig charlotte dass man in
deutschland keine studiengebühren zahlen
muss so wie in anderen ländern in
england in den usa muss man zum beispiel
sehr hohe studiengebühren zahlen ein
paar tausend dollar pro jahr in
deutschland heißt das aber nicht dass es
ganz umsonst ist es gibt eine kleine
gebühr
das sind meistens ein paar hundert euro
pro semester zum beispiel 500 euro pro
semester also 1000 euro oder 1200 euro
pro jahr
das muss man bezahlen und dafür bekommt
man leistungen von der uni man bekommt
zum beispiel auch ein ticket mit dem man
who bahn und bus fahren kann man bekommt
zugang zu der büchereien und so weiter
aber ja es ist nicht ganz umsonst aber
im vergleich mit anderen ländern ist es
sehr günstig
hallo
andrea reise schreibt roger gips us to
what you're videos for work greetings
from server das hat mich sehr gefreut
andrea das ist ziemlich wird sich für
uns weil ja wir machen das hier einfach
zum spaß oder andere leute müssen das
als hausaufgabe gucken sehr cool wenn
ihr auch easy german im unterricht oder
als hausaufgabe benutzt schreibt uns mal
einen kommentar darüber freuen wir uns
sehr sagt schreibt wyss episode jetzt
kommt eine beschwerde ein negativer
kommentar bis episode trend hinein ist
not understand the german is made for
like the german people who are
interested in the air is nothing for
learning german hier basic german in
levels to balance kellnert understand
entfiel ab setting especially when
speaking in der video ist noch
understand that all we need the german
tatsächlich diesen kommentar bekommen
wir oft easy german ist natürlich ein
scherz also der titel german ist nicht
easy und wir zeigen auch nicht immer
deutsch für anfänger sondern wir zeigen
deutsch wie es wirklich gesprochen wird
die idee mit easy german ist dass wir
euch helfen möchten dass das
komplizierte deutsch was tatsächlich
existiert einfach wird wir möchten das
schwierige deutsch einfach machen
die wahrheit ist aber deutsch ist nicht
einfach und man kann natürlich im buch
in der schule immer nur ganz einfaches
deutsch sprechen und man kann eine
kassette hören mit perfekter aussprache
aber wenn ihr dann nach deutschland
kommt und auf der straße mit menschen
spricht versteht ihr vielleicht nicht so
ist es mir passiert mit französisch und
andere sprachen
deshalb unser konzept mit easy german
dass wir echtes deutsch schreiben zeigen
manchmal ist es schneller manchmal
langsamer wenn ich jetzt mit euch
sprechen
versuche ich langsam zu sprechen aber
auf der straße ist das nicht so wenn ihr
zum bäcker geht wenn ihr in den
supermarkt geht wenn ihr ein ticket in
deutschland kauft sprechen die leute
nicht langsam mit euch
deshalb solltet ihr das lernen und
trainieren wo mit unseren untertiteln
ist es hoffentlich einfacher
krankentransport carré
das überrascht mich sehr ich bin easy
german fan solange gewesen und hoffe
immer dass du einmal in meine heimat
fliegt und dort ein video machst jetzt
ist mein wunsch schon verwirklicht
ich bin so glücklich ich wünsche euch
alles beste um mehr nützliche videos
machen zu können
vielen dank das hat uns sehr gefreut
tragen wir haben viele kommentare aus
vietnam bekommen und es war auch für uns
eine tolle zeit wir waren zwei wochen in
vietnam wir haben viele easy german fans
getroffen viel über vietnam gelernt und
wir wussten selber nicht dass deutsch so
populär ist in vietnam
es ist sogar auf platz sechs wird nahm
ist auf platz sechs unserer zuschauer
liste und das war für uns ja eine
besondere zeit
danke für all eure kommentare und für
alle menschen die wir dort getroffen
haben es war eine wunderschöne erfahrung
heute sind wir in singapur hier haben
wir noch eine konferenz und am mittwoch
fahren wir zurück nach deutschland dran
ihr schreibt liebe kari du sollst alle
spezialitäten und typische gerichte in
vietnam probieren ich schwöre dass du
nicht darüber bereust herzlich
willkommen in vietnam
tatsächlich haben wir sehr viel leckeres
essen gegessen und wir kennen uns schon
ein bisschen vietnamesisches essen denn
auch in berlin gibt es sehr viele
analytische restaurants aber jetzt haben
wir noch viel viel mehr kennengelernt
und ich bin ein großer fan von
vietnamesischen essen du auch ja sehr
jannis liebt vietnamesisches essen also
wir haben alles probiert nicht ganz
alles aber viel rapid rashid a thief
beschreibt carré please take me you ever
you go lucky you i love you so much
dankeschön rashid ich hoffe auch dass du
nächstes mal mitkommen kannst leider
können wir nicht immer alle leute
treffen unterwegs und das ist auch
traurig unser nächster kommentar ist von
jetblue und er schreibt hallo karin
haben sie lust nach indonesien jakarta
die hauptstadt zu fahren und das war
sehr schön für uns denn seitdem wir in
vietnam sind und gezeigt haben dass wir
ja in verschiedene länder reisen
bekommen wir so viele e mails und
nachrichten auf instagram auf facebook
mit leuten die uns einladen und sagen
bitte kommen nach indonesien bitte
kommen nach japan gekommen nach in den
iran bitte kommen nach ägypten
und wir wollen wirklich viele orte
besuchen und wir machen das auch immer
wieder zwischendurch aber natürlich
können wir nicht alle besuchen wir
werden euch auf jeden fall auf dem
laufenden halten und wenn ihr wollt
folgt uns einfach auf instagram und auf
facebook
die beiden links findet ihr in der
beschreibung und dort seht ihr auch
immer wo wir gerade sind und welche mit
absolut planen in den nächsten monaten
werden wir tatsächlich noch ein paar
orte besuchen unter anderem ghana und
hongkong
falls jemand von euch dort lebt schreibt
uns mal einen kommentar wir freuen uns
immer sehr denn es ist uns eine ehre
euch zu treffen und kennenzulernen
das war ein kurzer gruß aus singapur
ohne untertitel
ich hoffe ihr habt ein bisschen
verstanden und am mittwoch sind wir
wieder da mit super easy german
aus singapur sonntag easy gemen aus
vietnam
tschüss und bis bald
[Musik]